claire will you marry me
yes
claire crawley's dreams came true on the
bachelorette
in record freaking time it feels very
surreal it happened a few months ago but
it's still
so fresh and i i could not be more
excited yep
the 39 year old hair stylist got engaged
to 31 year old dale moss
during episode 4 of her season on the
hit abc
show we're gay we're engaged
oh my god we're we're engaged right now
yeah
and just so you know that proposal went
down
roughly two weeks into filming i
couldn't be
more excited to take this journey with
you i'll see you inside
all right i'll see you soon i feel like
i just met my husband
oh my god yeah sparks flew from the
second they met each other on
night one and on friday the two appeared
on good morning america to talk about
their love
and that magnetic first encounter after
we had our first group date
in my mind and in my heart uh everything
was already written so
everything after the fact just validated
that and
i knew in my heart that it was going to
be her and i at the end of
the end of the day after an honest convo
with the show's host
chris harrison claire officially dropped
her bachelorette duties and had her
first one-on-one date with dale
where they professed their lovee love to
each other
but before they got that happily ever
after claire had to break up with
16 other guys
awkward it was incredibly hard because
as much as i believed in us and do
believe in us
um still having to break up with that
many guys at once
that came there at shot of love with me
was
really hard yeah yeah yeah but back to
that proposal i said from the beginning
there was never a time i wouldn't be
there for you
um and my heart was so full and i knew
exactly what i wanted to do so
uh never a second second thought and
if you see even in the episode we're so
relaxed and we're so calm
together and we knew at that moment we
were
exactly where we were meant to be claire
admitted it's been tough dealing with
all the hate over her choices leading up
to her engagement
the things people say without knowing
the full truth and without without
seeing
exactly how things really happened and
genuinely happened um
it just blows my mind but she had this
to say to all the naysayers
i guess i just honestly want to send him
love because i think hurt people hurt
people
and when e.t chatted with chris harrison
last month
before the big engagement news was made
public he reminded fans the whole goal
was for claire to find
love i'm not mad at claire none of this
is a bad thing if claire's falling for
somebody and that's where this goes
then great like the whole purpose of
this is to help claire find love
and if we help claire find love of great
if i do it in record time that should go
on my record that should be a good thing
um so that that there shouldn't be a
negative to this
as for the show the bachelorette is
moving forward with tasha adams as the
lead
the 30 year old stepped in for claire on
thursday night's episode
and when eti caught up with claire last
month she had
nothing but praise for her i wanted
tasha as the bachelorette
a while ago like i support her i think
she's beautiful
i think she's a very grounded woman a
woman who knows what she wants
um i completely support that i've
supported her
i wanted her to be the bachelorette
forever i always was for that
on thursday shortly after tasha made her
bachelorette debut
she appeared on jimmy kimmel live and
said the whole thing went down
fast af honestly i got the phone call
and it was more so just like
hey you're the girl and i'm like i got
you and i was there
watch tasha's journey to love as the
bachelorette tuesdays on abc